لن تتركنا امريكا وسفي بوعدها هكذا قالتها
كيف والاتحاد الاوروبي يقدم وعودا
للاوكرانيين تفوق وعود الامريكان وي ل
كثره تلك الوعود التي كسرتم رؤوسنا بها
فالوعد دين غير مدفوع كما يقولها العرب
بينما واشنطن توجه امرا بسرعه لتغيير
الاستراتيجيه الحربيه على ارض المعركه
وحشود عسكريه ضخمه تتجه صوب روسيا
والامريكان يدركون حقيقه مواجهه الدب
الروسي ويعترفون بها فعن اي اعتراف
يتحدثون والنيتو يعلن عن الدول التي تدعم
الحرب ويكشف عن اسلحه نوعيه قد تحسم الحرب
في اوكرانيا في الايام القادمه والسودان
يصدر مرسوما دستوريا بشان الدعم السريع
والبرهان يحط رحاله في قطر ومجموعه العش
تكافئ الاتحاد الافريقي وانقلاب الجابون
يقوم بخطوه غير متوقعه تجاه الرئيس
المعزول واشنطن وثقه الاوكران اوكرانيا لا
تملك شيئا في هذه الحرب غير الثقه
بالولايات المتحده ووعودها والثقه
الحقيقيه امر نادر في ايامنا هذه يا ساده
وهو نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اليكسي
ميل نيك يقول انه واثق من مواصله الولايات
المتحده لجهودها في دعم بلاده خلال حربها
مع روسيا مضيفا ان اوكرانيا تملك ترسانه
من الداعمين تصل ل 50 دوله حول العالم
وانهم يقدمون ما في وسعهم لتعزيز القدرات
الاوكرانيه في مواجهه العدو الروسي هل
تقوم هذه الدول بما ذكر مل نيك حقا ام انه
يستدرج جها بكلامه المعسول اما في الجانب
الغربي فالامر يتغير من حين لاخر فالدول
الغربيه ترى انها بحاجه لتبني استراتيجيه
جديده ما بعد الهجوم المضاد الذي تشنه
اوكرانيا على الجيش الروسي اذا كانت تريد
ان تنتصر في الحرب على روسيا ووفقا لصحيفه
فورن افيرز فعلى الاوكرانيين التاكد من ان
الغرب على استعداد لدعمهم في حربهم من اجل
هزيمه روسيا لكن ماذا لو لم يستطع
الاوكران هزي روسيا وهو ما يحصل الاجابه
تاتي من موسكو التي اكدتها مجددا بان
الغرب يريد القتال حتى اخر اوكراني فيا
لها من رغبه وهنا خرج الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي خلال لقائه في كييف
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
محذرا من شتاء صعب ينتظر الاوكرانيين
واضاف زيلنسكي ان كيف ستجتاز الشتاء مع
شركائها الغربيين سويا بدوره اكد بلينكن
ان الدعم الامريكي سيستمر على المدى
الطويل لجعل اوكرانيا قويه مضيفا ان
واشنطن تريد ضمان ان تكون اوكرانيا قادره
على ردع خصومها على المدى البعيد وليس
مجرد النجاح في هجومها المضاد في المقابل
قال الكريملين ان الدعم الامريكيه المقدمه
لكييف لن يغير نتيجه ما سماها العمليه
الروسيه الخاصه في اوكرانيا لكن مهلا مهلا
عن اي نجاح يتحدث بلينكن فيما تقول مجله
نيوزويك الامريكيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تفقد مواردها على الجبهه الجنوبيه وهي غير
قادره على شن اي عمليه واسعه النطاق ضد
شبه جزيره القرم الروسيه واضافت ان كييف
لا تمتلك السفن او الطائرات التي تحتاجها
للحفاظ على سيطرتها على البحر بمفردها
والعين الاوكرانيه ترمق الدعم الغربي
كالعاده لتتخذ امريكا خطوه خطيره لطالما
حذرت منها موسكو وذلك باعلان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن عن تسليم
الاصول التي تمت مصادرتها من الاوليغارش
الروس لاوكرانيا لاول مره والتي ستستخدم
الان لدعم المحاربين القدامى الاوكرانيين
اليكم المصدر كما نتصفح امامكم في موقع
سبوتنيك العالمي لياتي الرد الروسي على
لسان المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديمتري
بسكوف الذي قال ان كل حاله من حالات
المصادره غير القانونيه ليتي ام وال واصول
روسيه في الخارج ستتسبب بدعوه قضائيه جديه
وان موسكو لن تترك هذا الامر يمر ببساطه
فهل وصلت الرساله يستدرك المحلل العسكري
الامريكي سكوت يتر الامر بقوله ان
الولايات المتحده لن تدخل في نزاع عسكري
واسع النطاق مع روسيا لان الجنرالات
الامريكيين يدركون عدم قدرتهم على تحقيق
النصر وشدد على انه لا في سوريا ولا في
اوكرانيا
ولا حتى في اوروبا لا تملك الولايات
المتحده فرصه لهزيمه روسيا وشهد شاهد منهم
ونحن لم ناتي بشيء من عندنا ليدخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الخط فقد افاد معهد كل
الاقتصاد العالمي لان دول ومؤسسات الاتحاد
الاوروبي وعدت بتزويد اوكرانيا بضعف ما
وعدت به الولايات المتحده من مساعدات في
حال احصاء مساعدات جميع الدول الاوروبيه
فان حجم المساعده وده يصل الى
156 مليار يورو وفق وكاله نوفوستي وبينما
يحاول الاوروبيون دعم اوكرانيا على المدى
الطويل وزل نسكي يهدد سلطات الاتحاد
الاوروبي باللجوء الى القضاء وذلك في حال
تمديد القيود على استيراد المنتجات
الزراعيه الاوكرانيه وخطب زيلينسكي بشكل
منفصل المفوضيه الاوروبيه قائلا ان اساس
اوروبا هو المنافسه الحره والوفاء بالوعود
فيما يخص المعارك قال الامين العام لحلف
النيتو ان دولا عديده مثل هولندا
والدنمارك والنرويج اعلنت استعدادها
لتسليم اوكرانيا طائرات من طراز اف 16
والى الميدان حيث اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه مقتل 17 شخصا واصابه اكثر من
30 اخرين في قصف روسي استهدف السوق
المركزي في كوستي نيتين فكا بمنطقه دونتسك
وقد ندد الرئيس الاوكراني بالقصف وقال انه
يجب الحاق هزيمه روسيا في اقرب فرصه ممكنه
لمنع تكرار مثل هذه الهجمات والعده على
المصدر كما هو موضح امامكم اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه مقتل 17 شخصا واصابه اكثر من
30 اخرين في قصف روسي استهدف السوق
المركزي في منطقه دونتسك وقد ندد الرئيس
الاوكراني بالقصف وقال انه يجب الحاق
هزيمه بروسيا في اقرب فرصه ممكنه لمنع
تكرار مثل هذه الهجمات
هذا وقال ضابط استطلاع في اللواء رقم 200
التابع لاسطول الشمال الروسي والذي يعمل
ضمن مجموعه القوات الجنوبيه انه تم رصد
حشد قوات اوكرانيه كبيره في المناطق
القريبه من ارتي مو بيسك ووفقا له يتم
تعزيز القوات الاوكرانيه المتواجده على
خطوط التماس في تلك المنطقه بكميات كبيره
من الذخيره في المقابل اعلنت الدفاع
الروسي عن تدمير 117 موقع تمركز لقوات كيف
وتحيد اكثر من 750 عسكريا واسقاط 41 مسيره
وكالعاده المصدر هو من يتحدث الاحداث
والتطورات اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في السودان الفريق اول ركن عبد
الفتاح البرهان مرسوما دستوريا قضى بحل
قوات الدعم السريع وامر البرهان القياده
العامه للقوات الشعبيه المسلحه والامانه
العامه لمجلس السياده والجهات المعنيه
الاخرى بوضع القرار موضع التنفيذ هذا وحط
البرهان رحاله في دوله قطر مع بعض من
قادته لاجراء مباحثات سياسيه وفقت مجموعه
دول العشرين على منح العضويه الدائمه
للاتحاد الافريقي في اجتماعها المقبل في
نيو دلهي بحسب ما نقلت شبكه بلومبرج نيوز
واضافت الشبكه نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه ان هذه
الخطوه ستمنح التكتل الافريقي الذي يضم 55
دوله نفس الوضع الذي يتمتع به الاتحاد
الاوروبي من تسميته الحاليه المن ظ
الدوليه المدعوه بشكل مفاجئ ورغم اتهامات
الفساد الموجهه اليه اعلن الرئيس
الانتقالي في الجابون الجنرال بريس اولي
جن جيما في بيان بثه التلفزيون الحكومي ان
الرئيس المخلوع علي بونجو حر في التنقل
ووضعت السلطات الانقلابيه في الجابون
بونجو رهن الاقامه الجبريه منذ ان اطاح به
الجيش في ال من اغسطس
الماضي
[موسيقى]
e